[Applauso]
oggi il porto in viaggio con me dietro
aule universitarie in cui persone senza
tetto ci insegnano le politiche sociali
ci insegnano cosa succede di notte nelle
città quali sono le soglie della
resistenza cioè quei posti dove puoi
stare senza ricevere violenza ci sono le
persone che rispondono quando suoni
all'una di notte quelli che non lo fanno
assolutamente oppure diporto nelle aule
con me sempre del corso di politiche
sociali in cui i detenuti insegnano
quale sia il senso della pena
dentro una condanna di ergastolo
ostativo che cos'è la rieducazione che
cos'è la restituzione oppure ancora in
corso di sociologia della
globalizzazione che nelle sue aule a
migranti che hanno appena attraversato
il deserto e il mediterraneo ci
insegnano che cos'è un debito come si
contrae un debito di 30mila euro per
arrivare dalla nigeria li time e
soprattutto come lo si restituisce o
infine un corso di globalizzazione in
cui le donne migranti ci insegnano un
mondo post coloniale in cui l'unico
punto di arrivo culturale non è più
l'occidente
cosa succede in queste aule in che modo
docenti testimoni esperti
dell'esperienza e studenti costruiscono
rappresentazioni del mondo condivise e
in qualche modo un po contro narrazioni
rispetto a quelle che siamo abituati a
consumare questo ve lo dico dopo perché
vorrei tornare prima su questa idea la
docenza universitaria partecipata da
dove nasce e soprattutto com'è che io
l'ho accettata e che mi sono legittimata
a utilizzarla nella mia vita quotidiana
effettivamente diceva bertolt brecht è
un mondo strano quello in cui noi ci
troviamo a vivere un mondo cioè dove
numeri sempre maggiori di persone
studiano l'intelligenza collettiva
cresce
eppure davanti alla complessità dei
problemi
queste moltitudini continuano a ripetere
e minoranze continuano a governare ea
redistribuire al loro interno ciò che le
moltitudini producono che mondo strano
quello in cui la conoscenza che aumenta
coabita con le disuguaglianze che
aumentano senza che le moltitudini
protestino ci fa riflettere questa
osservazione sul fatto che le forme
attraverso le quali noi insegniamo non
abilitano tanto le persone ad affrontare
la complessità con coraggio a darsi il
ruolo di mutare il mondo quanto
piuttosto le formano a ripetere
immaginiamo le classi dove tutti noi
abbiamo fatto lezione abbiamo ascoltato
abbiamo ripetuto e questo va avanti va
avanti e ci illude che sapere cose
astrattamente ci renderà capaci di vita
ecco allora l'idea di una formazione
diversa situata in cui il ruolo del
docente dell'insegnante dell'educatore
non è tanto precedere in forma stratta
le rappresentazioni della vita reale ma
accompagnare le persone le nuove
generazioni ad attraversare la
complessità farsi garanti di scambi tra
mondi diversi gruppi sociali diverse
certo che la teoria è importante ma
aiuta a generalizzare le informazioni
che nascono dal dibattito comunità di
apprendimento in cui le età sono
mescolate in cui la scuola è
un'occasione per gli adulti di
raccontarsi
quando ho letto queste cose questi
pensieri che la pedagogia la psicologia
la sociologia
ho appreso piano piano aveva già
partorito mi sono detto ma è molto bello
e molto interessante eppure mi sembra
impossibile
e come sempre accade come spesso almeno
accade è stato un viaggio a farmi vedere
che invece era possibile perché molto
spesso c'è questo gioco ed è questo il
bello di un mondo globale quando ti
sposti e vai altrove ti accorgi che
quelle che per terra un topi e da altre
parti sono possibilità concrete e allora
rive di un po l'equilibrio tra possibile
e impossibile e nel mio caso è stato un
viaggio di studio in brasile non molto
tempo fa la prima volta è stato nel 2012
ero andata per studiare altre cose il
bilancio partecipativo le forme di
democrazia diretta che da loro sono più
istituite e più presenti rispetto al
mondo europeo ma sono inciampata sulle
università situate grandi intellettuali
che sono anche docenti da omar almeida
emerso merito
cardboard ccme mi mostravano porto
allegre un'università in cui sociologia
del lavoro poteva svolgersi nelle
fabbriche sociologia della salute o
antropologia medica dentro gli ospedali
sociologia dell'educazione o pedagogia
nelle scuole elementari
e così erano gli operai insieme agli
studenti a comprendere anche grazie al
ruolo dei docenti cosa sia lo
sfruttamento o il cambiamento del
capitalismo oggi oppure erano i bambini
delle elementari insieme agli studenti è
certo ai docenti a rappresentare che
cos'è il potere e come si esprime nelle
forme dell'educazione
oppure ancora erano i malati insieme ai
medici ai docenti a concettualizzare che
cos'è la buona cura tornata in italia mi
sono detta non stiamo per niente andando
lì
riguardando dopo un viaggio la propria
realtà la serie analizza ed
effettivamente ho visto un università
sempre più affannata che rincorre un
mercato che rifiuta gli studenti
diplomati laureati è come se
l'università davanti alla
precarizzazione del lavoro aumentasse le
nozioni aumentasse le specializzazioni
aumentasse l'astrazione del sapere per
rendere le persone più adatte al
presente più adatte a dire sì ci sto
accetta un lavoro in cui io sono molto
creativo in cambio ricevo poco ci sto a
mantenere il presente più che a
cambiarlo proprio la direzione opposta a
quelle di comunità di apprendimento che
mettono al centro il cambiamento come
oggetto del sapere
e allora ho riflettuto però sul fatto
che in fondo un docente dentro le aule
ad un margine di libertà può organizzare
le proprie lezioni e così piano piano
con dei dispositivi prudenti ho iniziato
a invitare dei testimoni questi
dispositivi prudenti si sono via via
organizzati hanno creato alleanze con
associazioni movimenti collettivi che
preparavano come le elezioni e adesso vi
accompagni un pochino a vedere in queste
aule chi viene e che tipi di saperi si
producono la prima aula in cui vi invito
come vi dicevo prima è quella di
globalizzazione in cui
donne migranti che fanno parte di
un'associazione che si chiama tavolo
sguardi incrociati all'interno del
centro interculturale di parma si
trovano prima delle elezioni per
produrre narrazioni autobiografiche ci
raccontiamo le nostre infanzie le nonne
ci raccontiamo cose che abbiamo tutti e
si crea come una biografia collettiva un
blog una memoria di infanzia collettiva
per esempio attraverso la quale vediamo
elementi comuni e una volta che li
abbiamo visti siamo in grado di
confliggere e accettare gli elementi
della differenza produrre narrazioni
autobiografiche con donne migranti
insieme agli studenti produrre passaggi
autobiografici comuni per poter poi
attraversare davvero i nodi dei
conflitti culturali è un dispositivo che
funziona bene le donne per esempio
parlano di modi diversi di intendere
l'emancipazione non tutte vogliono
occupare lo spazio pubblico attraverso
il sapere tecnico il lavoro non tutte
dicono le donne migranti vogliono
correre come te
vincenza per esempio liberazione è più
tempo
non meno tempo ed è più tempo per la
parola sacra per esempio loro i ragazzi
restano stupiti davanti a donne che
hanno concettualizzazioni diverse
dell'emancipazione però poi scoprono che
tutte si sono defilate intorno ai 12
anni e che tutte lo hanno destato eppure
tutte si piegano a questa pratica ogni
volta perché ha tutte la gamba liscia
sembra prerequisito per l'esistenza
e allora si alzano alle studentesse
dicono forse potremmo partire dal fatto
di non deodorati più scherzi a parte
biografia parte appare un modo complesso
di concettualizzare le culture che non
permette più di dire agli altri
marocchini ta cinesità quando detestiamo
che ci rappresentino con l'italianità
oppure ancora un'aula in cui migranti
richiedenti asilo ci raccontano che cosa
siano i sistemi dei passeur queste reti
globali che permettono alle persone di
attraversare le frontiere in maniera
il legale a volte sono carretti che ne
di bestiame a volte sono taxisti che
arrotondano a volte certo laddove i
paesi europei rafforzano le frontiere si
costituiscono in organizzazioni blindate
perché più tu strutturi un muro più la
potenza di fuoco di chi lo deve
attraversare aumenta
e allora piano piano gli studenti
lezione dopo elezioni ascoltando le
storie le tappe migratorie di queste
persone cambiano sguardo il migrante che
affronta uno dopo l'altro le frontiere
africane oggi rafforzate dall'europa che
esternalizza le frontiere non lo vede
più come qualcuno che illegalmente
compie un atto ma come qualcuno che
cerca di arrivare a bussare al muro per
chiedere asilo perché il diritto a
chiederlo a 0 prima che riceverlo e se
non infrange quelle frontiere chiederlo
diventa impossibile si rivolta lo
sguardo elezione dopo elezione i ragazzi
iniziano a sperare che sia possibile
toccarlo quel muro è così le
rappresentazioni del mondo si fanno un
po più complesse la teoria sociale passa
attraverso pezzi di vita
l'ultima stanza dove vi porto è quella
del corso di sociologia dei processi
culturali che si chiama laboratorio di
partecipazione sociale
questa volta non sono pezzi di mondi che
entrano ma siamo noi che usciamo usciamo
e il corso che è di molte ore a 20 ore
diciamo più teoriche e 60 di
partecipazione attiva e quando 80 in
tutto dentro le associazioni di
volontariato della città grazie alla
collaborazione con il centro servizi
volontariato di parma forum solidarietà
e alla cooperativa ciac onlus che
gestisce il sistema sprar richiedenti
asilo e che gestisce le elezioni che ho
detto prima
grazie alla collaborazione alle alleanze
con questi soggetti è possibile far
scegliere agli studenti un contesto di
mobilitazione di azione sociale per il
cambiamento dentro al quale scelgono di
andare a lavorare in gruppo per un
numero importante di ore
questo è un elemento importantissimo del
lavoro in gruppo perché lps è un credito
di ateneo
non vuol dire molto per chi in questo
momento non sta trafficando con
l'università ma per me vuol dire molto
il credito di ateneo vuol dire chiedere
che un ateneo abbia dei corsi in cui
infermiere studia col filosofo il medico
con l'assistente sociale
l'ingegnere con l'economista
l'economista con lo storico futuri
lavori discipline oggi separate vengono
messe insieme intorno a un oggetto e i
ragazzi imparano che la realtà è più
complessa delle discipline e che intorno
ad essa si devono sedere insieme il
viaggio nelle stanze è finito è però ci
tengo a salutarvi dicendo che cosa ho
imparato io da questo che poi è l'inizio
di un percorso lungo ho imparato che
innanzitutto il mio lavoro di docente
universitario che io immaginavo come
molto strutturato in un'istituzione che
io sentivo come molto chiuso e
affaticata mi da dei margini di libertà
ci sono degli interstizi di possibilità
e la riorganizzazione dei nostri ruoli
ci sono degli ambiti di libertà
nell'auto definizione di quello che
facciamo questo è un po il modo in cui
interpreto oggi la possibilità occupare
con gli interstizi e agire in maniera
concreta una cosa che prima aveva per me
un alone di fascino ma appunto mi si
presentava meno concreta che la
responsabilità professionale
ecco a dirla così dicendomi che cosa
ancora posso fare in quel poco spazio
far entrare il più possibile di persone
a condividere quello che sto facendo
cioè formare le nuove generazioni a
cambiarlo il mondo non ha manutenerlo
grazie dell'ascolto